vuitton of Antibes is it dilek Lee
located on the Mediterranean at this
time of the year there aren't so many
visitors and the harbor area and beach
sure at their quietest in the center of
the old quarter we find Lafitte year
desantis fee at michelin-starred
restaurant Christian mother says the
owner and chef the name of his
restaurant literally means the fig tree
of the Holy Spirit hit reply complicated
way I know it's always difficult to find
a suitable name I know path good
position even if I came up with the idea
because there's a fig tree in the center
of the terrace you like tall and the
restaurant is located on Holy Spirit
Street such as P the old promise I'll
market in antibes is considered one of
the best on the curtis here and offers a
wide range of regional specialities
christian alyssa is checking out
vegetables free fish dish the ball
public i'm looking for winter vegetables
like rutabaga and celeriac i'm going to
make a very fine mixture today out of
rutabaga celeriac and mangold with fresh
coriander did you call young fashion now
they say by his all his produce locally
next it's on to the fishmongers back in
the kitchen christian melissa gets to
work on the sea bass the six kilo fish
caught locally cast a hundred euros we
get the label here shows that the fish
was caught with a line when gdp she
allodynia a sign of particular quality
while Christian Molly says it's about
fitting the sea bass his son Radha
begins on the vegetables
he grates the rutabaga and then cuts the
pumpkin into thin slices he so today is
the vegetables in olive oil in a little
water for just a few minutes on your
butt would we don't want to dilute the
taste we're looking to bring out the
full flavor so each vegetable is cooked
separately we don't call it include any
given the chef then brushes the fish
with olive oil lucky i'm laying the bass
on grease proof paper otherwise it would
stick to the burner after seasoning the
fish with salt and pepper he lays it
together with the greaseproof paper on
the hot plate after just a few minutes
it's already done sea bass known as bath
in French is very popular in Provence
because of its firm white flesh the dish
is quick to make but is still a delicacy
a source is then made using the juice of
the vegetables the sauteed vegetables
are served with fresh coriander and a
basil sauce the classic Mediterranean
dish is a favorite with locals sea bass
with seasonal vegetables a classic at
the figure desantis free restaurant in
the heart of aunty